hi everyone it's Jerry this is a game
played in London in 1912 between Edward
Lasker and George Allen Thomas it's
certainly one of the most popular games
of chess ever played in in large part
due to not only the excellent
combination but the visual appeal of the
combination itself so let's have a look
at it we have Edward Lasker on the white
end opening with d 4e 6 the Horwitz
defensive very flexible mova could
transpose into French very easily after
II 45 but in this case we have after
Knight f3 f5 going forward Dutch
structure Knight c3 and Knight to f6 so
under the knight c3 move not the most
common move you'd see obstructing in the
C pawn typically when you have your deep
on advanced two squares that C pawn is
going to want to either play one or two
squares forward one to support your
Center two to maybe look forward to
striking at your opponent's center but
clearly that is no longer possibility on
the white end so after Knight f6 Bishop
g5 Bishop e7 more development we have
this Bishop for Knight exchange so so as
to allow this efore advance now if this
is something black wants to avoid they
could do that at this point right here
they could play after Bishop g5 they
could play d5 and you know efore isn't
gonna be played anytime soon and maybe
this Knight is not really the happiest
piece in the world it's just kind of
getting in the way of this pawn push
which is going to help out this rook
eventually if that pawn can get to that
c4 square and it trade itself out for
that d5 pawn one other interesting thing
to know is that I'm suggesting this d5
move only after this Bishop has first
committed itself to the g5 square like
if black got it and it said that they
were gonna play to stop this efore
advance with d5 right now you'll note
that that bishop has not yet committed
itself and so ii five is a direct
consequence of this d5 move you know
that this is a liability now it's a hole
in the black position you can very well
see this bishop now deploying itself to
f4 to watch
over that square so if you're gonna
maybe play the d5 move in other words
play it only after this Bishop has
played to this g5 square I think it'd be
a little bit better so that the bishop
can't just play to f4 and start to lock
down on that e5 square so in any event
we don't get to see that in this game
Bishop e7 we have the exchange of Bishop
for night and E for capture capture and
then b6 looking to just being head of
that Bishop now this this position right
here can actually come about there's a
very similar position out of the French
defense if you wear this pawn is
actually still on the f7 square so we
could just take a quick look and see how
that can actually come about for those
of you that are that are interested in
the French defense we could have
something like this where black takes
the knight captures the bishop plays
here and white will give up that Bishop
I've seen bishop or Pont X in this
position but you'll know that this right
here is very similar the only difference
is involving this f7 pawn in the game
that we're looking at today we have that
pawn actually on the d7 square instead
of f7 but as it was in this game we get
to this point right here where after b6
Bishop looking to get to that b7 square
more development well it scratched that
not more development the knight just
pivoting on e5 looking for this little
tactic of Queen to h5 giving check like
if black isn't careful there could be
the Queen check and then the knight
could capture here
and there could be really bad stuff
going on very quickly in particular this
Bishop is gonna be lost it takes this
guy is gonna go down so we don't have
that instead after Knight e5 black just
castles Bishop d3 Bishop b7 and now
Queen to h5 and this right here comes
with a very serious threat and it's one
which was completely overlooked by black
in the game we had Queen to e7 and
apparently black was looking only at
this as a possibility Knight take
bishop and with these two pieces
converging on h7 pawn takes knight would
be the best response so as to allow the
queen to defend h7 however let this be
let this game right here be an example
of in your own chess games making
certain to look at your opponent's is
most forceful continuations considering
those first is a good rule of thumb to
be going with so after Queen to e7 while
this right here is forcing this next
move is going to be even more forcing we
have a queen sacrifice taking on h7 King
takes Queen and this combination
altogether those of you that are
familiar with that popular toy the yo-yo
well we essentially have that the chess
equivalent where they kind of like walk
the dog we have a huge king walk in this
game and it finishes up in a really
really neat way Queen takes h7 King
takes Queen Knight takes Bishop and
discovered double check and double check
the king must always move if the King
goes to the corner little game the gamer
is going to end right away with Knight
g6 so instead these next moves are going
to all be forced in fact this
combination from this point right here
is a checkmate in eight so Queen takes
King takes Knight takes Bishop
discovered double check King h6 night on
e to g4 it's very important that it's
that night that moves there if the other
night goes here the king can actually
avoid a successful check at this point
right here there's not going to be a
good way to get at that black King so
it's very important to move the correct
Knight to this square it's night on e to
g5 all forced King g5 h4 check King to
f4 the only move
g3 check King f3 the only move Bishop e2
King g2 the only move root 2 h2 check
King to g1 and this game finishes up
with King to d2 a King move leading to
checkmate one other way to mate which
would have been pretty cool is just to
queenside castle and deliver me but as
it was in this game after
King 2d to a king move white is able to
deliver checkmate so that's all for this
video as always I hope you got something
out of it take care bye